good luck eric good luck
i'm assuming we're okay i'm muted myself
that way i don't laugh if anything funny
happens i'm gonna start your games
i try not to laugh it's two i am playing
chess i mean of course it's
you should see this prime comedy oh
you're i didn't prepare for you
what what what is this what i don't know
ah wait
what is this i'm like not used to
playing when i'm summoned to play i'm
not used to it either
this is a terrible terrible opening
but i'll try and survive so i just
played vincent keimer
oh oh you're warm oh you're 2900 what is
this
why is your reading so high they're
gonna nerf me pretty soon don't worry
that sounds fun yeah i keep getting
challenged by all the indian
grandmasters now because they know i'm
okay i think you're losing this is kind
of like our blitz matches
i know brings back painful memories
i'm not gonna give up so easily though
just like our blitz matches exactly
only down the exchange yeah honestly i
mean i've
i've seen
i've seen you save some positions also
colored bishops too
that's probably just a draw oh there
goes your rook
eric i was not prepared to not be
winning
okay so i wasn't prepared either i
wanted to look up your openings
i don't i don't play openings
ah my thing oh my time
too oh no my time
oh your bishop i have enough pawns i'm
not scared
really no i'm very scared
good i did not show up here to lose
i think i might be doing just that
though
oh you're like so good at this
transition oh thank you
oh my goodness
oh i'm sorry you deserve to win that you
were crushing me and then
do they expect us to talk do they expect
us to it's
so hard to talk during bullet i'm sorry
i'm getting like
challenges from like grandmasters now
trying to
trying to trying to take my rating all
right eric it's it's
oh it's london time what opening is this
i didn't prepare
god how do they expect us to talk well
it's not easy
play like i i know i normally do it but
this is like this feels a little bit
more prep look at my panda
oh it's a pawn diamond
that's so i have a pawn smiley face
my mind is better ah
oh what what is this what is it not
oh my c pawn uh i feel so backwards
how are you not down on time i feel like
i'm playing so fast
and you're just not losing any time i
feel like a hermit crab
what does that even mean i don't know
you just want to draw are we gonna like
dirty primo flag each other
okay draw yes you probably
hey okay all right look that was come on
but you should never offer a draw on
your time and then wait and let your
time tick down it's just a pro tip
all right all right click click the
rematch button
why are you doing this i don't know i
don't know it's really bad
but i can't help myself
why am i doing this yeah i
i really don't know like
this is deliberate oh my god oh my thing
it worked last time though it barely
worked i'm just not used to
having forced conversation all right i'm
being i'm chained to my chair right now
this is this is unpaid labor oh
but if you win then it's paid well
that's an extra step okay and i like
guaranteed you know i'm i'm a show money
kind of guy
really i don't know i'm just
saying things out loud please just take
my pawn
oh what is this move oh that's a good
move
stop you're debating me stop it what
i'm just gonna let your knight sit there
is that a free night
oh oh oh oh no that's like oh
you know what that was so sick danny
sent me a message
and i had time to read it yeah that
makes me feel bad
yeah so she get for surviving that first
game
eric don't castle queenside don't don't
do it i'm not gonna do i'm gonna castle
kingside
like pillsbury this is like a classic
pillsbury
doughboy attack
oh
what are you in pain i don't know i just
remembered the previous game
it was kind of painful
how's your day so far oh it's been good
you know did some commentary
um it sounds relaxing trying to win my
queen as he's small talking me
what am i am i gonna am i dying here
what
if you're dying then you probably want
to have some last words
that are meaningful right
i i don't know i haven't thought that
far ahead
really actively trying to save this game
really
oh my thing i forgot rook's move
and straight lines
don't hurt me
i don't really have moves you know like
i can't really inflict pain in this
position
oh it makes me feel good
all right it's first of three right oh
so i have drugs right
is it win by it's not win by two it's
just
fight till the death i'm i'm gonna win
with this
oh oh we're repeating our line
oh i don't remember my theory is it like
this
i make the theory here i know i'm scared
now if i lose on this it's going to be
really bad yeah
i still want to buy your e4 course
because you're like the leading
expert on what how not to play
on this opening i think
it's very generous of you to say but i'm
not i'm not sure how true it is honestly
oh okay i'm having flashbacks from that
game you mated me
that's good flashbacks are good
for me oh wait that's
like bad for me the trickiest player
i i've ever
just as you say that you tricked me i
didn't
didn't trick you you you were lost when
the opening appears oh yeah that's maybe
true
stop hurting me
i was going to say i enjoy it but that
seems
danny said that oh did he
kind of
rooks could move like that
no oh yeah this is the part where you
don't this is the part where i
get stalemated hopefully correct yes
but but no um it's
okay that's okay i'm just trying to
mentally recover
oh you know you and i would come down to
the last game yeah no it always does
right
at least i'm like what happens if we
draw uh we split the money
oh draw hmm
no that was a joke i think
but feel free to take your time
[Music]
okay this is this is a main line
oh this line i wasn't actually thinking
to play
theory here but you know we'll do it
i'll play theory
oh i actually prepared this for you like
during our lunch
oh oh thanks great yeah outstanding
i forget all my prep though me too i
forget your prep as well at least i have
the bishop hair
no this is bad you're not supposed to do
that yeah you know i don't think you're
supposed to do this i have two bishops
dark souls are weak what darks dark
squares
what what are you i mean they're so
juicy
you know i am starting to yeah
this is what uh this is why you
subscribe
to the chess.com channel for
if you have twitch prime you can
subscribe for free
right yeah yeah i i know
um oh that's a good move
i'm very focused i'm very much i'm
nervous are you nervous
i'm kind of nervous a little bit yeah
how do you cope with nerves
by hanging my rook and you know oh was
it free
oh your queen is free
oh that's me oh you should have taken
the draw eric
yeah taking the draw life is filled with
regrets
good games i hope they broadcast this on
a not popular show and not the most
popular one like this better not play on
magnus versus for hum
i'll be very upset or the magnus versus
speed chess championship finals
maybe